Somebody was telling me about this.
I was at a little kid's party and I was
talking to one of the dads and he was
telling me, um, about this,
uh, thing that happened,
this,
I think it was in northern California.
It was a fire in fucking might not have
been northern California was a fire.
And um, the, initially they
thought it was just a fire,
but then the CEO and his vice president,
we're both of their houses caught fire.
So then they thought it was like an attack
on bold people and then they realize
no,
it was a murder.
And one of the guys killed the guy and
his family and then lit his house on fire
and then went back to his house and lit
his own house on fire to make it look
like they were going after both of them.
And he's the only one that survived.
Yeah. Whoops. That just happened in
New Jersey. A Guy, he's in New Jersey.
Maybe that was it. A guy murdered his
whole family. His own family. Yeah.
And then lit the house on fire.
So maybe that's it.
Maybe I'm getting a fucked
up version of the story.
I get drunk a kid parties too.
Oh,
it's the only way to go by family
massacred disguised as a massive fire New
Jersey. Yeah, that's it. This
is the story. So, um, make
that a little larger please.
It says a, there was more than a brotherly
bond between Paul and Keith. Yeah,
that's right.
Part of New Jersey
vacation together and settled about 11
miles from each other in the suburbs in
New Jersey.
But two days before thanksgiving,
a horrific chain of events would forever
tear them apart. Oh, his brother. Yeah,
that's what it is. So I was getting a
really fucked up person. This story,
Paul, how do you say that name?
Kenario. Ken Arrow. Arrow.
Arrow Kenny. Oh, candy churros
brothers killing his youngest brother,
his sister in law and their children.
Oh, this is what's fucked up. Like what,
what,
how does a guy go from never killing
anybody to killing a wife and daughter?
So he killed his brother and
his brother's whole family.
Oh my God. I thought he handled
his own. Danny said is home,
home on fire with his
wife and daughter inside.
Tried to make it look as if the
whole family had been targeted.
His family got out of the home
safely. Oh, can you imagine the panic?
Like what the fuck man murdered these
people don't scroll, go back, go back.
You let your own house
on fire and you're like,
can you imagine like while your lighting
your house on fire thinking like the,
the intensity of this is going to work.
I'm going to get out of this, this, this,
this is where the plan goes and Poof,
it's really fun.
How does a person kill?
I mean I understand you're mad at a
guy and you fucking hate each other.
Fuck you.
And you start fighting and then
you wind up killing each other.
How do you kill his wife and
daughters? How do you do that? What,
like what switch goes on?
Like is he just trying to yeah,
cause he's just walking around and
go back up. It says it's killed.
His sister in law had
said he's [inaudible],
he's accused of killing
his younger brother.
His sister in law and their children.
Like how many, like who would, hey,
you killed kids.
Yeah.
So this is a guy who's never murdered
anybody just walking around cults.
Nick Township, New Jersey.
Yeah. He's a businessman.
Probably never done anything really
major in his life. Probably like,
was that a, uh, like a business meeting
like two days before with some guy?
What the fuck man? Just living his
life, talking about the giants.
Like what the fuck? What is that?
His wife and his two daughters.
Oh,
several twists in the case of Matt,
he then allegedly said his own home on
fire with his wife and his daughters
inside.
Did you not hear me say that?
I thought you were talking about
is his brother's family? No. No.
He killed his brother and his family.
Set the house on fam on fire.
Then led his own house on fire to make
it look like he was being targeted.
I knew that, but I didn't
know his, he had kids in, yes,
his wife and his daughters were inside.
Oh my God.
To try to make it look as if his
whole family's being targeted,
his brother and him. Oh my God, it's
family. Got Out of the home safely.
Wow. Fucking unbelievable. Think
about his kids right now. We're like,
what? To dead? What? Yeah,
what Jesus Christ. He,
oh my God.
Killed before sunrise.
Scroll up there. Somewhere
between midnight and 5:00 AM Paul.
Kenny Arrow was walking
around his brothers.
One point $5 million colts neck
home armed with a knife and a gun
husband in front of the white mansion
with a deadly confrontation unfolded.
Paul fired multiple shots.
Striking Keith fucking a when you got
mad at me for not following the story
clearly. Did you feel like you
could kill me? No, not yet.
I need more than need
more than Jesus Christ.
He walked inside, found his wife's,
uh, found Keith's wife, Jennifer.
He shot and stabbed her and
then stab their children.
Jesse 11 and Sophia Eight.
What the hell?
Then he took some documents
instead of firing them. You spent,
what were they doing like the week before
fucking stabbed an eight year old dude,
an eight year old girl in her sleep.
How do,
how to fuck to someone in
her sleep and her sleep?
Well, it was 5:00 AM it doesn't matter
man. He's, there's gunshots in the house.
The kids might have gotten
up. Oh my God, good Lord.
What a monster. A monster. What
was this guy like the month before?
Like what the hell could that normal
looking house shit that is the normalist
look normal house ever.
Do you believe that there isn't always a
presence of good and evil in the world,
like like that it's not just evil deeds.
What this guy did was evil,
but do you believe that there
is a real presence of evil?
That it's like a thing that
takes over people or takes over,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like, like, like good and evil.
Is that more than just people's actions
or is it like a force of nature?
Is there a good force of nature and an
evil force of nature that is constantly
using people and using things as,
as a catalyst or as far as a instrument?
Well,
let's break this down.
I don't think nature's the right way
to approach it because I don't think
there's good or evil in nature.
I think nature,
nature is actually far more moral
than humans are because what?
With nature's just about survival,
right?
Predators and prey and they
kill things and eat things.
But when animals in nature kill,
like what they call surplus killings
were wolves will kill like 18 elk and not
not eat them. They're just, there's
this going on their instincts.
These things are there
to be killed and they,
they can get them because
they can't run away.
Maybe it's thick snow or something
like that. So they just can't help it.
They just tear them apart because their
instincts are the drive them to kill
because that's how they survive.
That's other family survives.
They're killing and they,
they,
they're eating these elk and
this is just what they do.
And even if they kill a bunch of
them where they can't eat them,
their instinct is to kill because
that's how they survive. It's natural.
It's normal.
With humans it's very different because
with humans there's consequences,
right? And there's law and
there's other humans finding out.
So there's deception and then there's,
there's selfishness and there's the,
the fear of getting caught.
And then there's your own,
your own survival
instincts in terms of like,
you don't want to get locked up in jail.
You don't want to get
caught for something.
So I think if I had a guess that this
guy didn't think he was gonna kill this
guy's wife and family probably didn't
even think he was going to kill this guy.
They probably got into a heated argument
and they, they're stupid. And He,
you know, he's Guinea, he's, that's my
people. They do stupid. Your people too.
Canny air, they do stupid shit. You know,
they're, they're fiery people. And those,
those fiery people.
I swore off Italian girls and I was 21
I had an Italian girl take a swing at me
when I was 21 I was like, that's
it for me. I'm done. I'm like,
I'm not hitting one back.